Welcome to the Data
Science Hang on everyone.
The first one since PositCOMF,
for all those that I met.
It was great meeting you.
This is your first
data science hangout.
Welcome if this is your
one hundredth or more. Welcome.
We're happy to have you.
I'm filling in for
Rachel Debsey today.
She's ordinarily the the host.
She's taking a well
deserved vacation.
So I'll I'll do my best.
This is a casual open environment
for data scientists,
data science leaders interns,
students, what have you?
So we want it to be a
free flow in conversation,
super welcoming. So, you know,
use your best judgment Be nice.
There's lots of different ways
to participate. You can, chat in.
Hannah will share a slide
or link where you can ask
anonymous questions,
you can raise your hand,
you can turn your video on,
you can, to sort of speak,
so it's super casual,
whatever works for you.
I'm really happy to introduce our
leader today, Jean Bison, from Nestle.
So I'll hand it over to him
to do it to a do an intro and
we'll get started. Okay.
Great. Thank you very much,
for the the nice intro. And,
yeah, just to to to build on,
what you've just said,
I've been assisting to,
I would say some
of these, these,
hangouts,
honestly, it's it's also
sometimes collapsing,
but it's in the end of
the day here because I'm in Europe.
So sometimes it's a bit
difficult to attend, but I just
want to reiterate
that, it's a really,
it's a pleasure for us to
be here and to Anor. Anor,
to have been asked you to share
my my experience with you.
And,
and just, I'm ensuring then
this experience as a person.
So, just to make sure
that, everyone is also aligned on
this. I'm not here representing Nestle
as a Nestle employee. I would say,
but I'm happy to share
with with my experience throughout
my, different
companies also and the,
and more recently in
this day, of course.
So speaking of which
I actually, medicated as a
physicist, I did,
at physics in the Swiss
Federal Institute of Technology in Ozan.
And then after that, I did
a PhD in a neuroscience So, what
I have, and I was exploring
the connection, between
neurons, doing more biophysics,
and, that would be
through electrophysiology.
That's where I started to
do some, data analytics.
Or rather,
heavily involved in in,
both analyzing
the signal to get,
some relevant features out of
that and then doing statistics
to to get the the,
yeah, what would be,
the,
what would be the,
the message or
learnings to get
from that. Basically,
I was exploring how
neurons were connecting and disconnecting,
over a twelve hour period.
With, with actual
slices of tissue.
Then after that, I
moved to the industry,
and then I started to work
as a process engineer in,
Valtanic Technology, which
is a company's license,
with, also a production site in in
Solum, in the US, in in Ohio.
And,
I worked there, so as
a process engineering macro, electronics,
to do assembly for medical
devices. We are working on,
outside medical device, but
also some, some implants,
and that was a bit more
challenging because
And that's where we have this,
this neuroscience also that
was interesting for for the
company, within the
neurostimulator.
So I've been there,
successively,
process engineer then head
of, engineering, and development.
And then the head
of technology,
taking care of the the the
the the portfolio of technology and
interaction with customers.
So taking Vatronik
is a service company.
So we don't have the we didn't
have any direct product,
but we would, develop
an industrialized products for customers.
And then,
after seven years
in that company,
I moved to Nestle
as a data scientist.
And then I,
there, I worked in
different projects,
in the system technology
centers. So, is located in
Auckland, Switzerland,
where this,
this is the center where
we develop all the what?
So called system. So system
is the conjunction of the machine,
dispensing machine,
the packaging,
which is functional to
some extent more or less,
but sometimes more than less.
And the product,
and one of the most known
is Nespresso. I would say, the Nespresso
system with the the virtual lines
that you had in the in
the US or,
we also have Dolce Gusto and
different things like this that are,
around that. So
I I worked there,
really in different project
as the data scientist,
with the land of experiments,
with this statistical process
control with also some automating,
data analysis that we're coming
from the labs where the lab
would generate a lot of
different files and we would
need to have some,
apps that would then,
and that would be shiny apps
then. I know it would be
using, and analyzing the data
to to extract the the knowledge
of it, and then drive
the drive the development And,
recently.
So this summer, I moved
to necessary research.
So moving a bit away from the
production I say closer to, to more,
upstream,
process in a research
and development.
And now I'm,
still working in, you know,
in in in programming
and having these,
on,
more applied in
the food science.
And so it's a broader than
just the systems tree touching all
the necessary categories there.
Aside on, say,
part of my activities
also understand that could be
interesting and that's why
I'm sharing it also with you
because there might be
some questions, also around that.
I've very early
in Nestle joined
the network. So we have
knowledge networks in Nestle.
In r and d where we
actually connect,
different people
from different sites,
just to give you an idea,
I don't know exactly
how many sites,
but I think we have sites
all over, the, the globe.
And,
then sometimes that I
scientists are there one of
their kind or maybe
two of them. And,
it's good to connect so that
we can share on experience.
We can share on on tricks.
We can share our own knowledge
and, and also, get some
some coaching and and,
and entering also, each other.
So this data in its network,
I've joined when I joined it
almost at the same time. And,
more recently, I've been in,
or for a week for some time
already in the leadership team.
And for the past two years,
I've been needing that network.
It's already coordinating the
the different activities for
the net this network in the,
in earnestly. So,
so what that's a bit,
about my history.
In a in a in a short
term. I don't know.
I haven't looked at the,
at the questions.
I don't know if you could what
some of the questions are we if
there is any question on this?
Questions questions
typically come in, you know,
maybe starting now. So if you
have any questions, you know, please
type into the chat or, you can
use the slide or you can just,
hop on, with video and
audio. I see Mike actually,
has a question, Mike.
Nice to see you.
Yeah. Hi there. John. This one.
So what is the size of the
data science group at Nestle?
And I'm sorry if I missed this.
Well, I didn't mention.
So that's a good question.
I would say that,
it depends how you how
you define data typically, the network,
so I will start from my
closed community or my closer to me.
The the network, I mean, we
are typically around fifty.
That would be for R and D, fifty sixty,
but not everyone with center
completely exhaustive.
And they more
recently did, data
science.
So,
and and these people I would
say would be more really in the
in the development and
kind of hard coders. I would
say also on people either using
r or or a or Python or both.
But then when you extend
also to a lot of analysts,
that would then be also
using some more less coding
or no code solutions.
It becomes bigger. And when you
look at also beyond R and D,
would say a number that
came recently up is something like
around a thousand.
A thousand knowing that Nestle
is three hundred thousand
people around the world,
including all the factories,
of course, and then you
can have a very diverse,
approaches because we have
people in the in the business
who would be, more looking at
you know, dashboards,
I would say it's really
around the data visualization,
which is already,
teaching a lot. I mean,
basically having a just
showing what is there. I mean,
how many times I've got people
coming to me with an Excel
sheet and say, oh,
we see this and this and this
on the numbers and I say, yeah,
well, try plotting your data.
And that's one of
the thing we say,
also in the in the in the
the the course we give is is really
plot the data the
first thing to do.
So this is already very
valuable and, here,
typically using for our BI,
type of solutions. Also,
we have many people in
the business doing this.
There is also a lot of
activity in the supply chain, that I've,
held off for for the
demand planning and this kind of
thing. So there are there
have been things like this.
And,
any in various
fields of nestle.
So that's why when you extended
beyond r and d, it goes,
it goes there, but it might
be in also approaches and,
and techniques that
I'm less familiar with,
as I'm much more
into, I would say,
technically generated data or,
yeah,
machine or instruments
generated data. Yeah. If I may,
can I have a follow-up
question then, Rob?
So,
when you were talking about the
communities to try to bring together,
you know, data scientists
or practitioners then.
So is that primarily your fifty
or is that actually reaching out broader?
Now it's primarily the
fifty, I would say,
because it's it's
really much more around,
doing the same activity.
Well,
we've seen here in the in
the hangout so we have some
commonalities across what the
different activities of the gas
centers, but, we also
have, might be quite different.
And I think that
when you are treating
some some, I don't know,
data for supply chain
or human resource data,
or data coming from
a mass spectrometer.
It's not exactly the same.
So you have somehow the
same techniques behind, but,
also where we are more
than just machine or calculating
machines. These people also,
we are having some
knowledge about the domain.
And and typically, when I was,
you know, you know, I know,
now I think a lot about coffee
also because I worked for
coffee projects. And, when
I, I was there, you know,
it's releasing the connecting
the dollars for sometimes
because you're like, people,
they come with a request
and they have a certain perspective
from their project. And then
also as a data scientist,
you can say, well, look,
I I understand what you
what you would like to do,
and I can understand because I
also don't know what is the
context and what is the
science behind, to some extent.
I'm not pretending I'm as
a direct level, but to some
extent, we know this this,
and then we can, we can help.
So that's why this community, I would
say more in in r and d,
which is already pretty
challenge to manage.
Because we see that
we have a different, different,
also approaches
have to know that in in
Nestle R and D, we have,
so food science, as you know,
the most obvious our systems
then the product technology center.
So they've got the product that
you wish to find on the shelves.
We also have then Karina,
which is part of Nestle,
and you may well know. And,
but we will set health science.
And typically in the Institute
of Health Science that would be
more things around, you know,
more nutrients. So it's around
intake, food intake, but it's also,
regarding different,
type of product would be
delivered in the hospitals,
for instance, and that would,
then require different
approaches and clinical studies
and these kind of things.
So
it's already pretty diverse and
that would have been that is
still, I would say
a challenge to have
sessions where everyone is interested
in in the topic. So, sufficiently,
I would say
sufficiently,
we said that in English,
sharp in technically,
but sufficiently broad so that we
are not lost by the by the
science behind if it's not
in our, more familiar domain. So,
so yeah. Nestle is
a massive company.
Right? Like,
I'm I am assuming most
people are familiar with it,
but Jean Vincent,
do you wanna just sort of maybe
give folks a lay of the land
of, like, Nestle as an entity?
Well,
so I, as I've just said,
to give a number. It's around
three hundred thousand
people, around the world.
It's,
I don't know how many hundreds
or thousands of factories.
And then, what it has this
particularity, as I said, that it's,
it's kind of so it's a
Swiss base. Swis originally,
from so the the headquarters
are in Verde, in Switzerland,
by Lake Geneva. But she's
called Blacklenmore.
This because ladies and stuff has
a whole debate on the region.
And,
it's Swiss spirit in the
sense that it decentralized
even though there is a center
in Verdde, but there is always,
a a will to have,
products that are adapted
to the local markets.
So there is a some sort of
autonomy that is also given to
the different market.
So what we call a market is
not necessarily a country
but if it's a big country,
it's just a country,
but can be also a group of
of some of some countries.
And basically, well, it's
I think the first food and
beverage, company and our
main products and our, around
coffee, we are we are producing
a lot of, of Nescafe. Typically,
it's one of the one hundred
you mean also of of Nespresso,
as I mentioned, so Purina,
in the in the pet food.
There is also all the chocolate chocolate
k e. I don't know if, if,
how,
how there is,
how it's spread.
But there are also very,
there are products that
are typical to certain regions
typically. I think
Milo is South American.
So then there are many,
sometimes many brands that I'm
I'm even still discovering
that I didn't know existed.
So so it's it's pretty
broad. So but, really,
supplying a food beverage,
around the world,
I would say. Yep.
And your your previous
company, Veltronik,
is that is that the way
we make? No. It's how how
different is Nestle
from from that company?
Well, you had different
aspects. So first,
Verconic is five hundred people,
around the world. So it's,
smaller than one
center in this way.
Let's say they are in
necessary search where more than seven
hundred are located in in
Los Angeles around the Los area.
And, so in that sense, it's,
it is, is it was much smaller.
So, of course, you can,
have also responsibility
at a global scale
much quicker, I would
say, in a career there.
But still it was international
in the sense that Vatronique
has to quarters are in in
in Switzerland. There is,
well, there was at the
time a, engineering bureau in Romania,
and then there was
factory in Morocco,
a CF factory in Morocco in
the US, installed on the OIO.
And,
So there is still also
this diversity because in the sense
that, so the Marrocon company, plant
was ready to to produce, with a,
a less expensive,
workforce.
So it was more a decentralizing
but the US company was
a lot more autonomous and serving
more the US market. So there
was also there also this,
aspect of, offering,
this,
serving their local needs, I
would say, from the company.
Then it's different also in,
what the activities also is a
little bit different because we do not
do not develop electronic
devices in this way,
whereas a a battery equals
re owned electronic devices.
And, yeah, so I would say,
there there is also maybe the
the size of the company really
makes a big difference
in the sense that
well, there are
two things. First,
there there might be some
more in Vantronik because it's medical.
So aside from the medical part
of Nestle, but, and still,
Nestle is a food company.
So there is a lot of
constraints for around safety
for, for instance, adjusting.
But,
on the other hand,
initially being a really big
company needs to have, you know,
all of these process that
are inherent to every big company,
I would say. And Vartranik was
maybe a a little bit more, on
we can do different things.
But yeah, it's
still to to to a certain
extent. So then, I would say
it would be moderately
closer to a startup
even though while
I'm saying this,
I'm also thinking that some parts
of Nestle are also shaped to be,
like, I would say start
up, like, or have freedom.
So there is still even though
there is it's a big company
resort or the process
and everything,
which is giving also
a certain, you know,
security and coherence,
then there is also
this this innovation, and,
entrepreneurship that is visible into
some some areas of the command.
Yeah. There is a an
anonymous question asking,
what is the difference between
your role as head of technology
and now a data scientist?
I'm doing more hands on things.
That's a data scientist.
That was also one of
the goal. You know,
when you are head
of technology, it's,
the activity was a lot
around supervising,
people,
not supervising in terms
of people management,
but more in terms of,
technical outcome that
they were producing.
And there was also a
lot of activity around,
interaction with the the the
customers or with the the
prospects. So I would then work
with the with the sales people.
And then, you know, when they
they would come to me, oh,
I have this new guy
who'd like to do this,
and this is do you
think it's feasible?
I don't know if you've
if you're familiar with the,
with the the the the YouTube
video where it says I'm an
expert. I can do
everything, you know,
with the seven perpendicular lines,
with blue ink, that are red.
You know,
for those who are doing a
belt and then you would see these
are the types of
times of, you know,
you're the the
head of technology,
the the expert coming
in and and then
firsthand, say whether
it's possible or not. So,
and in that regard, I'm
not doing this anymore, at all,
as a data scientist in this
industry because I I'm,
I'm involved in the project.
I would say really
much more hands on.
And I might then,
that there is no
interaction with, I would say
customer who would have a space
project. It would be more
internal customers and
internal, project that are being,
shaped and, and, and developed.
So,
yeah, so so,
there there is this
hands on thing,
and I could really much more
focus on the API science activity itself
and develop also in that field that is
that is also taking off a lot with,
no more recently. Also,
on on on larger datasets
as well. Very good. Thank you.
There was a question,
posted by I think Neil's.
Sorry if I mispronounced
that, but Neil's,
I'll give you a second if
you wanna ask that yourself.
Otherwise, I can ask it.
Yeah. Sure. Can you hear me?
Loud and clear.
Thanks. Awesome.
Yeah. So my
question was around,
I think you mentioned
something about
collecting some some data files
from the lab using, shiny.
So I was just wondering you
could talk about the process of around
identifying
shiny as the correct
tool to do this.
And then whether you had
any interaction with the
stakeholder to get approval
for using it and then,
as an add on to that, what
development challenges did you
meet, if any, when using
shiny and, enterprise?
Thanks. Yeah. Okay. So,
basically, why using shiny?
It's because we're using r.
To start with. So, basically,
the the data analysis that
I've been doing, so I've,
we have an internal package that
the school has stats and that
I participated
to in developing,
some code around, design
of experiment analysis.
And, so just to say that,
we have a rather intense activity
using our, as as the
software for forwarding our analysis.
Especially when it comes to,
you know, sometimes
from the lab,
you can have
someone more automatic, automatic,
or semi automatic,
equipment that would generate a
lot of data, like protocols,
yeah, like robotic,
systems and things like this.
And, when it comes to that,
you have, a lot of different
files or a lot of files,
which are not so different.
They are the same structure but it's
a lot of them. And, you know,
copy pasting it in Excel.
I'm trying to do something out
of that is, kind of, painful.
And so, very quickly when
I come to this situation,
I would then start coding
in order to do the loading
automatic data running,
put things together,
have an graph with nice colors
using g g plots and so on.
So I'm a tidy versus
fan, by the way.
And then,
then then with with
this, you have your code,
and then,
you get your colleague from
the lab or from the project a
different thing. Hey.
That's very nice.
But now I have new files, and I
would like to do it again.
And the same analysis,
and the same display. And then
and over and over and over.
So after some time
you say, hey, look,
I can just package that
into a nice web interface.
And then,
and then you can do
it all on your own.
And then if there is
anything doing going wrong,
then you can just let me
know, and I will I will also,
I will also then update it.
Other things that could happen,
typically, to give you an example
why we've been doing this is
So while you start the secret
that the coffee machine is is
pushing water through a
system and then with water,
you have a system pressure,
and then so you have some
curves of pressure against time
or temperature against
time is kind of soon.
And then we are interesting,
to, interested in what is
you know, the maximum here, what
is the plateau here, what
is the local minimum,
what is the local thing,
and what is the variability.
So all these features
extracted that are, then
the directors into that.
And maybe we'll run their
own analysis on the features,
but you need to extract this feature
And a typical shiny app would be,
something where they could
upload the road data and then
get back a CSV file
where they have the features analyzed.
And extracted.
So now how did we manage
to have this in the company?
So I would say a key
thing is to have, a good,
a good relationship with IT
because the other the guardians
of the compliance for IT.
It's really important and
and for very good reasons,
especially in a company as
exposed as, as big companies,
I would say any big company.
And,
what it it it went. So the
the first thing that's I mean,
at some point I had also,
you can also have shiny
apps that you just like locally
deploy in in in in the computer
and then you can also have your
colleague, having are installed
and then you can just,
we set it by
these sometimes, by the
way, to have, kind of,
batch file to, just
start the process,
and then we double click on it,
and then it would open
automatically, orange, shiny,
behind, and then they
would have the the page,
but then it's sitting on their
computer and if we want to
update anything, then we need to
to go to their computer again.
So there were some discussion
also already from from the
center where people say,
oh, that would be interesting.
And then, you know,
connecting with IT,
you you managed to put
it into the sufficiently secured and
closed environment, but still
available in the intranet.
And then more recently, we
moved with Azure and then, then
it goes into into Azure,
with Azure solutions.
And,
and, and then that's also where
you can manage the access.
You can manage the visibility
of the the the virtual machine.
So now we severies is is
is about a virtual machine.
And,
and, yeah, so the the thing is
to have our IT counterparts, that are
aligned, with with
this. So, basically,
what we I was looking at
was I could describe the needs that
we had as as a programmers
and data scientists And then they would,
they they came back
with some proposal,
and then we moved together to
to have something set up and running.
So,
I don't know if I covered
the the the whole question because
you you asked me also,
yeah, how how do we,
is there any, well, hurdles
in the big company? Yeah.
We said they choose this,
I'm having the the
right the right people,
but it's also a matter of,
of,
of good compromise,
I would say because of course
you you are not, in the world
as, open source and or
you would not, you know,
typically our code
discretion into a git system,
but inside house,
which would not put our code on
GitHub because it's a private based company.
So you need to to have
this, this understanding and then you know,
also explaining what are the needs
that we have TPB and R
and D. We have some
needs that are,
inherent to research
and development.
We we cannot predict what
we will discover because it's
research and
development. I mean,
so that and and sometimes
this is a bit, you know,
difficult to,
to handle when you speak
with people who are used to,
deploy an app and if the app
is doing what it's supposed to be
doing and we know and we know
everything and there is no
doubt and that goes with it.
So there there was
also this discussions surrounding to
really understand each other's
needs and perspective because
you're gonna either,
go freely, like, say,
I'm r and d. I'm creative.
I want to do everything and
and and voila, I don't know.
You need to play also by the
rules for the good reason and understand them.
Regarding your comment about
good relationships with IT and
Travis, I see you, made a
comment. We do hear that A lot,
I like to sort of ask, like,
what are some concrete steps or
things that you can do to actually
build a good relationship
with IT because sometimes it
can be a statement akin to,
like, deliver a great
customer experience. It's like, okay,
well, what does that
actually mean and look like?
I would say,
yeah, the the good
relationship with ITs,
I would say like any
human relationship is,
understanding also the
the other's perspective.
It's it's really,
you know,
most of the time,
really in a very vast majority,
when someone is
is bothering us,
with some constraints.
It's not by pleasure or
just to make our life worse.
It's because they they need
to deliver on something. I mean,
they are also accountable for
something. And then, we need to,
to, to make sure that
that will also speak the same
same or not same language,
but at least we have the common
ground of an understanding.
So I would say that would be
one of the key things. I mean,
I remember, like, for instance,
yeah, there might be things
that you are not aware of,
typically on on some of the
data access or some of, of the
the the systems access,
you say, you know,
I would like to have
it open, you know,
in the the the
words of sharing, sharing storage,
sharing settings,
sharing everything.
And then they say,
yeah, but to see,
this and this got happened
and actually did already happen and
you didn't know that.
So listen to the stories
that they have to tell us
where it comes from all these,
this frame that was put
in place. And and afterwards,
it's even better because once
once it's it's well set, then
you can really work in a in
a confident manner in in a in a
safe environment.
So, yeah, I would say
understand and listen to to the
other, but also,
be able to explain your
your perspective and your needs,
in in a in a,
In a most objective way, I would
say, but online needs to, to say,
to say, yeah, I need to.
This is how I, I see him.
And then I see someone
is commenting one good
relationship with the IT. Do
not lose patient. Yes. Absolutely.
I think patience is
also a good thing, but,
but yes, I'm not saying
I'm succeeding every time.
Sometimes I've made, I'm,
I'm, you know, we're passionate.
I would say, but, yes, it's,
try to to understand also
their perspective. They're,
I wanna go to the anonymous
questions. There's a few of them.
One is
do you miss supervising people?
Do you still supervise people?
I find that it seems
like an inevitable path to progress,
but I don't know
if I'd be any good.
That's a good question because
that's exactly one of the
reason I moved also to nestle.
So I think it's inevitable
to do some sort of supervision.
Now, the the great thing as, as,
have the chance to have in
in a sense that we have,
a path where we can
develop expertise.
And that's what I've chosen.
So I'm not developing into
managing more and more people,
having a group
than a department,
than an institute or whatever.
I'm I'm more developing
the expertise in data science.
But still with a certain
level of seniority,
you people come to you and
ask you for help ask you for,
feedback ask you for
having some, you know,
can you have a look at
what I've done and then tell me,
and then also people that
ask you, well, from your
perspective, what strategic
decision would you recommend
So, you know, at some point,
you take this also, span, when
when when when you
were growing, in the career.
So,
that's why I say it's
inevitable to to lose some sort
of management. So I would
say I have I more have,
I don't have direct
people as of now.
But I have, you know,
indirect or dotted line type
of of relationship also.
I may supervise sometimes some some students
or or in in in case like this.
But it's it's more,
yeah, something.
I wouldn't say like,
coaching and and
type of activity,
still with the reconciliation that
goes with it because I've
got experience sometimes that,
I've got some feedback where,
yeah,
senior leader would ask some
project manager to who's
presenting the project, these are
the computers and then, oh,
did you check it with Jogasaw
and then if they say yes,
then if they say,
okay. That's fine.
So you kind of the
the the validation of the expertise,
and he goes with the
responsibility because if it fails behind,
then that's somehow also your
credibility that is at stake.
So, I would say that,
yeah, that's really something that,
that is an offering I
was in a unique area.
There was an
anonymous question.
I think it would refer to
a previous conversation.
It's what is a
head of technology?
I guess the implied
question is like, well,
what does that entail?
But while that is exactly in
this line of not having a typical
direct reports,
at the time, I will just,
transfer so into the different, groups
and,
so I would be the go
to person if there is a technological
question, in in the company.
And then, also,
trying to coordinate across
the different groups or different
different activities.
So that would mean
you know, reviewing what
the different engineers are doing,
giving them also some
some feedback on on on the
on on the results that are sustained
and maybe also some guidance
how they would do the next
experiment or how they would
uh-uh address the next, process,
challenge.
And then
he also being the consignor,
for a relationship
with outside.
So when someone is
coming and seeing Okay.
I would like to do
this new implant with that technology.
Do you think you can bring
me a solution with this? And then,
with having discussed result and
having an overview of all
the project
technology speaking,
in in the company that you
can have a good, insight and think,
well, we think we can do that
this in that way, in that way,
or, with this and this,
challenges or in that
time frame and so on.
So that would be also
the type of activities.
There was a question,
and sorry if I'm pronouncing
your name wrong, from Hancock.
I don't know if you
want to join in.
I see you're on see you're
on video if you wanna join in,
but I'm happy to
ask it as well. Hi.
Hi. Hi.
Yeah. Jordan,
thanks for the insightful
things that you have been
telling. It's really helpful.
One question was more around,
shiny application
that you are using.
What kind of database or
data store or data warehouse?
So would you typically suggest,
as a back end for
shiny application.
And, majorly, when there is
a huge scale, we are talking
about, like, hundred, two hundred
GB data, in the back end.
Well,
that's a question maybe for
some of the positive control
channels so that would give
you a, a more complete answer.
To be really transparent.
I I'm not dealing with
that big databases.
But from what I know that,
that that we have been using,
then I would say
our chosen solution
is around Azure I would say a
cloud based solution is is something that,
that would,
that would be I would
say the preferred solution because you
will not download two hundred
gigabytes on your on your
laptop. It's not
that won't work,
and you need to to to scale
up your your computing power.
Which is, which is,
I think something that is
really a big advantage of of
cloud solutions in general.
They have this flexibility
of computing power.
And then,
yeah, I'm not sure how much
for shiny apps you can handle
size of databases,
but definitely what you can do
also is have some back end pre
processing because depending
on what you want to display.
I mean, in the end,
you may not want to display
the the the the hundreds of
millions of points. You want
to display some summary data,
some some knowledge
extracted from it.
So I would we then from
what I know, I mean, this,
I wouldn't maybe use things
like, you know, data bricks or,
or all data factory in Azure.
I don't know about, about
Amazon and and Google Cloud.
So that's why I'm speaking
about this one. So I'm not,
you know, sending anything.
It's just that I'm speaking
about the experience.
And then you can prepare your data
and then your shiny app can then,
get the the the the relevant
data that is, that is,
then useful for
for this plane. So
and it depends also on on
the application because while I'm saying this,
maybe you want to recalculate
some things based on the full
data sets, depending
on what is the user,
what is the user input,
but I would really,
try to,
to take care of having
as much as possible,
pre processing data with things
that where you can call, very,
very, powerful clusters
I I don't know if you
if you had mentioned a situation where
you have some data and then
maybe once a day or once every
twenty four hours
or twice a day,
you would have You would
turn on the very powerful cluster.
It is a lot expensive.
Prepare your data, save it somewhere
in the data lake or in,
structured database,
shiny works well with,
I've done some shiny application
with, with, with, with, with,
Yeah, Azure data lakes. So
it's really like a file system.
But you can also work with
the with SQL detectors very very
well that are in the in the
cloud. There is also on,
you can work with
with cosmos DB
that I'm a bit more
flexible. But then,
are we imagine something like
what you have your big storage
then your data bricks would, in
r and Python, you can do both.
You can, then would query
and then get your data, analyze,
save it in a way that is
prepared for the shiny app so
that the shiny is a lot
more reactive when it has really the
minimum data it needs to to
be efficient and to serve the the
needs. So it really depends
on on what you need.
Because if you want to
program or to get to recompute
everything every time you have
a query or a reactive action
that is done on your app,
they need to be very likely crashed,
quite quickly. So so I would
yeah prepare this in that way.
Understood. Thanks thanks
a lot, John. Ahmad,
I see your hand is raised.
Yeah.
I had a quick question.
A little bit about my
background is beforehand, I used to,
have no coding
experience whatsoever.
Had to learn as a
means to an end.
And so I've just had a data
cam subscription and was
frantically searching on Stack
Overflow before my deadlines and,
things experience that I had
was a little bit stressful and
to be quite frank, I
was a little intimidated, sort of,
stepping into this newer space,
a more technical space. And so,
Jean Vas, I'd love to get
your perspective on if you've had
any experience with coaching
and helping other people lower
the barrier to entry
in terms of,
learning how to code,
learning how to apply code
coding principles so their data
science work
because the initial,
barrier can be a little,
a little daunting,
a little scary at at
least in my experience.
So I'd just love to
hear your experience about playing that
mentor role. And if you have
any tips and tricks for us,
Yeah. Sure. So,
first, I would say,
the the key thing is that the
person starting should be,
well, think if you
are interested into the into
coding, then that's that's a
very good first step. People,
there is the first
barrier is people,
some people are scared by the
code and and some are not.
So if you are scared, I would
recommend you do something
else, but if you're not, then
it's a good it's a good thing.
And then I would say,
Yeah.
Maybe two, three tricks, but
maybe they're the kind of
obvious. You can, have some
example code. Typically,
you never you rarely start
from nowhere. So you always have
more or less good quality.
I mean, I
well. So I started
also coding in my life.
I didn't know I
wasn't born coding. So, so,
sometimes some of the other
people who didn't give me some
some some part of code that was
okay and then I could start
reading it and understanding it
and then, adapting it.
So you can have a first
thing is that this is your example
code and then,
and then adapt it.
So maybe having a colleague
that can give you also some
things. And then,
something that is that is
really would say helping is to
do not hesitate to have regular
sessions like weekly or you
just review the code.
And,
even if you have a question,
then you can go, yes, Stackflow or,
yeah, I'm not sure that that
Chad GPD is doing a very good
job. I thought some
hallucinations.
So double check with
the internet as well.
Then it can help, and and then
you can you can, but I have,
I mean, I've stuck with the
flow of the load. Of course.
And then,
then it's it's good to have
it's good to have also this
session. Let's take an hour
or two hours. Sometime in the
week, We sit together,
explain me your code.
That's what are the
different intentions. Comment your code.
I would say also don't hesitate
to put comments even for
yourself. This is
what I'm doing here.
This is what I'm doing
here, and this is, you know,
just a few a few notes,
and,
and then with someone
where experience can then,
propose some some
alternative way of doing the
analysis or alternative way of
uh-uh or more
efficient way. And
Yeah. So so in terms
of of coaching,
it's that there there is this.
Because, yeah, sometimes it happened to
me that, you know, I get,
I get,
to read you a code
with someone and then,
you would say, yeah,
but you can do it a lot
more efficient this way.
So it's not only a
matter being, you know,
computationally
efficient. Sometimes, yes,
because it takes several
minutes of hours to compute.
So you you better have
something more efficient that
is really dramatically,
reducing.
But at some times also, it
helps also the code to be clearer.
And then if you have a
elegant, coding, then In the end, you
also have a better
understanding of what is
happening and and you you keep track
and you you avoid hidden mistakes because
in the code, you can
have, cases where,
the the code doesn't work
and it gives you an error.
That's kind of easy.
You will have a capital letter
somewhere that it was not
there. You don't have
the right package. Okay.
That's kind of quickly fixed.
But I would say the most
problematic error is for any does everything,
and then it outputs something
that is not supposed to output.
And if you cannot spot
that, that's that's pretty complicated.
So what does when you have
a clear code and an elegant code,
you can you can
more easily follow.
I would say what is going on, and typically,
yeah, that that's
where things like,
while we have been, yeah,
in entire universe again,
almost the pipe, and
these kind of things,
and we can have
something that is a lot
easier to to to follow.
And,
and sometimes what can be good
also is to set some challenges
and I set myself at some
point. I said, now from now
on, my code in R will
have zero for loop.
I did everything without
follow. First is more efficient,
and sometimes it helps you
also think a bit differently.
But with apply, typically
with everything around,
applying map, map to the map,
whatever you have, the map, the,
then, you can do a
lot of things and,
and then you have this,
this, also,
way to, to to have
something that is
working. And I would say,
it also helps developing the
functions aspect So it's it's
also good to say, okay, I
can have a function doing this,
a function doing this,
and you build your,
you could learn this way.
It's also in the clarity part.
This function is taking
my data from this to this.
And then I have a nice
team to take into this.
It's the mechanism.
Do not agree with me since
it's not more efficient
to use. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
There is this parallelization
that you can use.
But but I well, I I
had some examples,
that actually was, was,
we have more efficiency.
We can we can debate this
in a specific thing FPD.
There there is one thing that
is, a lot a lot efficient,
is, however, don't forget that
r is using, in is,
I mean, use metrics
calculation.
So typically, the worst thing to
do is to can't through data frame,
because, and always think that you
can use the object and and,
and manipulate them
as such. Travis,
I see you asked a question,
and I'm very curious.
Where are you dialing in from?
Oh, San Diego, back back
home, I guess these days.
I don't I admittedly don't
know a lot about food science,
but I'm so I'm in the
pharma side and the notion of whether
or not you have to
submit data product sir,
kind of reports to the FDA
or other regulatory agencies,
do you have to do so?
There's a lot of conversation
in the pharma biotech world
about how to do
these things with R.
It's often met with some
resistance just because they're
more used to seeing SaaS.
I wonder if that's a
thing you've had to come across.
Oh, well, I haven't
personally come across this.
I know some people who are
sensitive also software reuse,
in this. They are not
personally using it has been used.
I'm not in that part of
the the the process. So,
unfortunately, I
cannot give you,
any details on this.
But they are,
there are clearly,
a lot of activities
around around that anyway,
or because we have
the safety specialists
And we have even an issued
order that is dedicated to for safety.
So, so this is
really something,
the separate and probably
they've been doing submission
also to FDA, especially if
we speak about health science, development.
But beyond this, I'm
planning for that.
I don't have any experience in
in that in that regard for what
it is. Yeah. No worries.
Thanks. No. It'd be
interesting, you know, as as
a follow-up sometime, you know,
the the conversation, I think,
is often dominated by
the pharma and biotech world.
But I imagine you all struggle
through the same sorts of things,
on the food science
and health science.
I'd be interested if we all
chat together, you know.
Okay. Yeah. Sure.
Let's burn through a
few anonymous questions.
How much freedom do you have
regarding the tools that you use?
As much as I can justify the
need, I would say in a sentence.
It's true. We cannot use anything
we want. We need to use approved,
tools.
But As far as I'm concerned
from my day to day work, I
have, a lot of them. So I have
a lot of tools and I have,
I would say more than if enough
tools to use.
Sometimes I come across things
that would like to implement.
And then, yeah, the process is,
we we can come with a proposal,
but then we we first need
to come with a with a requirements.
We we need we need to do
this and this and this.
And these two answers my needs
because of this and this and this.
And then,
IT would come back and tell
you, well. Maybe you can use this,
which we already have announced at
I wasn't and sometimes it happened.
I was not aware of something and
then I I have a new tool I
can I can use?
That is actually answering the
needs. And if really, there is,
there is a good reason for,
for handling a new tool,
then then that's okay. I
mean, it can be approved and,
and then we can
move on to to visit.
And I double click and
ask what what is the,
If you can share the process
for a new tool, right,
so you discover something, it's
amazing. You you wanna use it.
How do you go about, you know,
bringing that into
the workplace?
Or what advice might
you give to others?
Well, again, as the coming back
to IT security, I would really,
or come to,
first talk to to IT,
representative to say,
I would not come saying I
have this neutral that is great.
Please die it because
that don't work.
I would come say, Hey,
you know, I've come across this
time. In my, in in my work and,
do you know anything about,
that would help me
with this particular
challenge. I have that by the
way is answered by the two.
I found out.
And then in the conversation,
you can maybe suggest it
and see whether they they know
about it or not. Because it's
a lot more, you know, okay,
saying, and you can say, I
may have a potential solution,
but this is really
what I need to have
as first to be to be,
to be answered in
terms of, of of need.
And then you can you
can propose a tool.
I think what's,
how do you navigate the the
line or sort of adopting open
source tools? Right? A lot
of the times, they're they're
free. So you can just sort
of, you know, download them.
Maybe there's not a purchase
necessary. How do you go about,
or how do you navigate
not over involving
IT, but keeping
them in the loop?
Well, first, some
of these free,
tools that are already,
many many of them are,
have been approved because, you
know, IT kind of also, he is
doing the the the job in terms
of, scouting and being,
aware of what is is
going on typically with,
we have the examples with
with chatty and you know what
happened with with Samsung.
So, very early, we had some
communication internally
saying, we know there
is this coming out.
Please be careful
about this and this.
So technically, we are not,
if it's an open
source and free tool,
that doesn't require admin rights
to install a new machine.
You can do it, but then
you are responsible for it.
I think this freedom
also always comes with responsibility.
So,
I think it's okay.
And if you if you address
it this way also with,
with the
with IT who is also responsible
for the for the overall
security of the of the company.
Then
then it goes in the
right direction because you say,
look, I would like to use that.
It's always good to have
the double check and maybe,
ask the question.
You can test it on your own
personal computer at home. Say,
I have done some
tests at home, and,
it looks good because
of this and this,
What do you think flying
it into the into this?
And if you have
this reflection,
so you may not need to for edge
and every step go to to them. But,
if you have behind also,
the reflection also, okay,
What would be, you know,
kind of doing a sort of
a light risk assessment,
also regarding the company and
taking into consideration the company's
need and perspective.
Then after some time you get used
to it and say, okay, maybe this,
I'm pretty confident I can do
some test and and I've used
some reflection and then
you can just double check,
and some other things you
would ask, from start because,
you know, it might not
be, so straightforward
Yeah. Just make sure that,
that you have also
this kind of, you know,
rational and reflection on all
this.
Very good.
There is a I wanna make sure
we get to all of the anonymous questions.
So we're coming to the top
of the hour if you have any
burning questions,
submit them on Slada or
put them in the chat, but,
one that we didn't get to
so far is what are your
aspirations for the future
in your role? In your role or
longer term? Well, that's,
he's an HR question.
No. It's really I I
think I'm really interested into this
whole field of
Well, basically
trying to get
knowledge, you know,
extract knowledge and
understanding of the phenomenon,
from from the from
from the data,
and we have more and more
data. So I would say,
really going in in in
in this and being also,
aware of what is what is,
what is is emerging?
I mean, recently,
we have if you look at it in
in big history, we have been
having some some
statistics and then,
doing some linear regression or then
it came to run on Verizon.
I would have transformer architecture
that can be applied beyond
texts,
in some cases. So, you know,
getting more of these things
and trying to to connect the
dots between the
different things that,
that are available or that
emerge also from from the
academic research, yeah, to
we say continue in in
that field. So then,
by doing this, it it's,
in terms of professional, you know,
development,
typically in the expert,
in the expert, expertise
aspect, we can then start to
also give lectures in in
some universities or in some schools
and then to see,
to also share the your
your knowledge here and get the
feedback also from from from
different from the students and
from different people.
So I I would say, that would
be an achievable evolution.
You know, it's also to to
grow to reach beyond the company.
For for this, and
which is, by the way,
aligned with with the
the company. So, company
pricing.
Very good. So I think that
wraps up the, anonymous
questions, and I I don't
see any outstanding ones in the
chat. Obviously, feel free
to raise your hands, everyone.
I like to typically end or or
ask, like, not to put you on
the spot, but I guess
to put you on the spot.
What advice do you have, for
data scientists or aspiring
data science leaders.
Leaders in, in particular.
Yeah, well, You
have many different,
angles here, but if I
had I had to pick one,
I would say,
it's evolving, very, very, very
fast. So I think, being curious
on new things and,
always trying to,
with moderation,
of course, because you need,
also to to deliver and to be
to be efficient. I would say
yeah. Vincher,
so what what is coming up and
and and the new discoveries, and then,
don't hesitate to to to
test these new things on,
to see if it performs
better than the current techniques
that you will have so far.
But then also,
keep the as a leader,
keep the right balance between
having new things and still
selecting the time for the
people that you are maybe leading,
to to learn about them and
and to still delivering what they
have to do in their
very dynamic. Because, you know, sometimes
you have to, you have these
new things that you want to try,
but still the projects are
moving on and and good old
statistics or mocked classical
approach is also delivered well.
So there is a good balance
to find between between the the
house today with what
you know already.
That you're having missed
curiosity and openness to to
try new things that may
also open some new opportunities.
Are there any particular
avenues or channels that,
you use and occupy to stay
up to date and and learn new
trends? Well,
I would say, I I get
some some news, some
news that are coming,
from, you know,
what do I I'm not registered
to a specific journal.
I would say it's
more, you know,
during,
like this.
Sometimes also,
there is no one channel. I
would say really it's really,
therapeutic. I was, as
well as the question,
I realized this
because, you know,
sometimes I get something on
LinkedIn and I'm, like, oh,
that's interesting.
And then I pull the spread
and then see what, what,
what's there. Also,
most of the time,
we have a specific challenge
to solving a project and then,
there is a company or the
owner that we can work with.
Then that would be the
standard would prove, you know,
to to better, to
better understand it.
So I would say it's
three more opportunistic and systematic
way, I would say. But maybe
that maybe I could change this.
That could be a good, but,
so freight was that way.
Very good. Well, we are at the
top of the hour. So, Jean Minseng,
thank you so much for
your participation and and
leadership today.
If folks wanna
ask you, more questions or
get in contact with you.
What's the best way to
to connect with you?
Well, I would
say LinkedIn. Linkedin, but,
don't,
I mean, just be careful to,
send a small note that,
it was during the
positive talk, pause it, hangout.
Because, you know, I tend
to, to to not accept LinkedIn
contacts if I don't know
the person, I haven't met, you
know, kind of a rule I said
for myself because, you know,
otherwise you get a room.
So don't hesitate to connect but,
leave a leave leave a word,
and, then, then we can,
most probably will come
back to you saying, oh,
let's have a chat and
then, and then we connect.
So it's a good rule.
That's right. But
include a note.
Very good. It was it was
nice seeing everyone.
Next week,
it'll be regularly scheduled
program with with Rachel,
but John Mixon.
Thank you so much.
I hope everyone has a great
rest of the day and week.
Thanks so much. Thank you
for watching me. Thank you, everyone.
See you all. Yeah. Bye bye.